foreign
listen I'm British born and by a
Nigerian race there were expectations
different ways I was supposed to go my
career options for one some of you may
already know as an African you get three
choices please repeat after me you are
going to be a doctor
doctor a lawyer
or a businessman
now I did a thing that brought on quite
a bit of stress that's me saying mum
babes I did my best but that's not how
I'm gonna go
I'm gonna be an actor
why do you want to prostitute your
emotions for money what's my mom's
reaction now in all fairness what I was
asking for was this complete abstraction
but the more I succeeded the more my mum
could see right her idea of what was
possible was being re-imagined
with me
I was a lead on the West End
I was about to be a part of a small part
and walk-on part in a massive film I'm
building my career and then boom
I'm falling apart and it seems I'm
dealing with climate anxiety
building my dream and watching the world
literally burn in front of me and very
little being done
and panicking
Frozen like a mannequin until I see
environmental activism happening and I
jump in but whilst on the protests and
in the meeting rooms a question Takes
Over Me
why don't these people look like me
why is it when I think about climate
activism I think about white middle
class people there's a white middle
class problem
a crisis that seems to require more time
effort money work to do or know anything
about and I'm talking about those that
have the privilege to think about
anything else but survival
it feels like people of color experience
barriers towards the Forefront of the
climate movement and it seems that the
reasons lie behind are underlining
principles of survival
to keep your head down
do your work
and don't get in to trouble
survives
and dare to thrive protest yeah but only
for imminent survival see we've got
family that's been in this country for
40 years and still feel like new
arrivals and we have a history of
disappearing in the night
shipped off to some place or just
mourned
no room for the Eco fight
I mean me fainty baligan on this stage
right now doing a TED talk I am about uh
four times more likely to have Force
used against me if I'm arrested than my
white counterpart
I'm about seven times more likely to be
stopped and searched and with a new
policing Bill and public order bill this
bias is only set to increase
noise restriction on protests
criminalization of protesters without
having to convict them of a crime police
can stop and search anyone saying they
have Reasonable Suspicion and threaten
peaceful protest tactics to fear is real
so you know
keep your head down
do your work
and don't get in to trouble
get yourself a piece of the pie right
but that suggests the payoff will be in
a world similar to the ones our parents
grew up in
London was hot boy
40 degrees one of the hottest summers in
history after one of the hottest summers
in history
some people can go outside plants were
either dried up or on fire countries
were either underwater or on fire this
extreme weather is only set to increase
if crops die well that makes food more
expensive affecting working-class
communities communities of color first
that world that they grew up in is gone
but what if and go with me on this what
if
climate change is just a symptom of a
bigger problem
and what if it is the same problem that
causes racism and sexism and ableism
what if all of these things are just
symptoms
of a bigger problem
ready
white supremacist patriarchal capitalism
it feels scary because it feels like a
concept
even though our society is quite
literally based on it infinite growth
with finite resources at whatever the
cost
those forms of Oppression wouldn't exist
if it didn't make someone money
I mean in the UK slavery plantations in
the Caribbean provided the raw materials
needed for industrial change and growth
in the British Empire money
not to mention the genocides and the
conquests more money The Liberation of
oil by liberators that deliberate the
price of Liberation whilst polluting
soil get that money South to Shell by
the way
who historically have taken oil from my
country of origin Nigeria Nigeria who
pollutes almost 10 times less than
England as do so many colonized
countries and you know it
it seems to me
that some of the people who are the most
affected pollute the least
the ones who've been historically stolen
from
climate change is modern colonialism
so we know with all of this with a
colonial mindset with a capitalist
mindset that even if we have a magical
technology that clears the air and makes
everything safe it would only operate in
certain neighborhoods we're dealing with
structure
a structure that told me to keep my head
down
structure and a media that chose to Omit
that six percent of the population
indigenous people protect 80 percent of
the world's biodiversity
chose to Omit that one of the most
important climate protests in history
was led by a Nigerian cancer we were of
the organic people chose to omit the
effectiveness of Grassroots movements
and Community Action people like Ben
wretched of the earth May Garden
projects to name a few chose to omit the
UK's constant investment in fossil fuels
takes away from any Aid it wants to send
to countries like Pakistan but did
remind me I should recycle more
if it is that structure that tells me is
about my own individual purpose and
guilt maybe it's worthless I feel the
powers in the masses
so I joined groups
local and in my job like cooking with
all my different hubs
one being equity for a green New Deal
pension divestment putting pressure on
Heels then I took lessons from cop watch
UK took me my rights with police arrests
and interventions Discerning their
intentions I learned I have to think
radically now
about strategy
and kindness
kindness for myself
and those right behind us to be held by
them and to hold right back well that's
Community right there is strategy
in that
then what's my capacity how much can I
give because I got rent auditions family
I gotta live and when I have my capacity
I think well what's my aim
where am I helpful how do I give weight
to my claims it's about strategy right
so why integrate well I speak to ignite
connect and always add detail let's go
back because this is important agitate
call out in action point to solution
tell the truth get all that money out of
so fuels pension Investments accounts
hand over power make them want to be
radical connect
there are people in spaces just like
this that need to be connected to
Grassroots movements who need the
attention the space the funding and
they need you
ignite
remind everybody watching that you are
not powerless
that the oh man there's nothing we can
do just keep going is symptom
not cure
that you stand on years worth of
resistance and success that you are
needed
that you
just like my mum
have the power to re-imagine
what you think is possible
so now we speak
we strategize
and we think how does this action Aid
The Next Step
thank you
[Applause]